hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game from the
uh chess 24 banter blitz qualifier
between uh norwegian grand master
arianthari
and dutch grandmaster jordan van forest
and it's quite the game like the title
suggests
it can happen to anyone and it is good
to know such things
so we're gonna check out the game and we
do have fresh news
about the candidates tournament 2020
when it will resume and where
well sort of the official announcement
hasn't been made yet but i will
talk a little bit more about this after
we check out the game so let's check it
out tari
uh with the white pieces opens with e4
and
as the title suggests uh uh a forest
goes for the scandinavian defense with
d5
uh e captures queen captures and knight
to c3 and we always mentioned that there
are
quite a few popular retreats here queen
queen can go to d8 to a5 to d6 uh
very popular nowadays even queen to e6
has been played even even by magnus
himself
uh but here we have queen to a5 the the
old uh continuation that is uh
well well known uh here we have d4
continuing with the
with the main stuff knight to f6 and
knight to f3
and here bishop to f5 a very popular
square to develop your light square
bishop
we have bishop to c4 uh white does the
same
and now e6 uh and bishop to d2 and this
is a position
after seven moves uh white is
threatening some nasty discoveries and
usually
when if you play the scandinavian or if
you play against the scandinavian for
example i've never
uh had any good discoveries here with
this knight and
when playing black um i've never really
had problems with my opponent having
good discoveries here
and here basically uh what you want to
do is you want to prevent
these nasty discoveries either by
clearing
uh this diagonal for the queen so the
queen can retreat if you play something
uh
like moving the knight or you can you
can counter uh white's dark square
bishop you could go bishop to b4
uh to prevent it like that c5 also has
been played here uh which does the same
only
uh in addition it attacks the center and
queen to b6 is a known move here
just getting the queen away from some
nasty discoveries but the one move that
was never played here
uh is exactly what forrest plays he
plays knight beat to d7
uh and now black is completely lost and
now
yeah you probably know what's happening
here but just in case uh feel free to
pause the video and win this game for
white
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on paying
attention and yes it's all about the
nasty discoveries here and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
knight to d5 and now this opens up an
attack towards the queen
the knight is nicely defended so the
queen cannot capture it
and you have a lot of problems first off
you
have to do something about your queen
being under attack but the only square
available
as these squares are not available uh is
the a4 square however if you go to a4
white has a lot of good options he can
just go knight c7 check pick up the rook
but even nicer is just bishop to b5 and
now the queen is trapped as
all of these squares are now taken uh so
that that's it for for the game uh
so after this knight the d5 move uh
forrest uh can
give up the queen if he wants to
continue the game so here even though
the game is now lost
uh why uh resigning is not very
fashionable
uh nowadays in online chess so the game
did continue here
so here uh you could capture this knight
and give up the queen for two pieces
like this or you could do it like for us
did with queen captures on d2
so queen captures on d2 and only now e
captures on d5 and bishop back to d3 so
now
black has two pieces for the queen but
it is uh far from
uh from from a playable compensation so
here we have captures captures
and bishop to d6 uh continuing
development we have castles by both
sides and a queen side castle at that we
have castle's castles
uh and now rook h the e1 we have knights
to e4 and now this is a this is a great
knight for black and the white will
definitely need to do something about
this
uh for the moment the df two pawn is
being threatened uh so tari defends it
rookie two and now
f5 cementing that knight but white uh of
course will kick it away king b1 a nice
prophylactic
move first rook h the uh e8 and now
you have to get rid of this knight this
knight is basically the only thing
holding black's position together
so knight to d2 just preparing f3 to
remove the knight from e4 and not allow
any pieces to land on e4 in the future
so knight to df6 and now f3 uh black
lost uh
the e4 outpost for his knight we have
captures captures and now
g6 and now uh what all white has to do
is
figure out a way how to uh push this
advantage into a win so g3 first we have
c6
black will try to create some sort of a
fortress but it's going to be very hard
we have captures captures
and rook to e2 white of course wants to
trade everything off and black will try
to hang on to some material
so rook to e6 and now uh we have kinked
the d7 preparing a nice trick and
white allows it here we have queen to e2
and now black finds this very nice trick
knight to e4 and traps the rook
but it's still uh it's still not enough
to call it a compensation so if captures
on e4
king captures an e6 and now e5 creating
a pass pawn
bishop e7 and now c4 now white will just
start pushing everything
uh forward so rook to d8
and c5 now closing the center with h5 by
black and now queen to e3 preparing uh
some infiltrating ideas with the queen
here
we have g5 preventing this and now b4
so now uh we'll see if white will be
able to push through or
will blackberry will be able to uh
create some sort of counter play on the
king's side so rook to f8
and now queen to f3 going after the pawn
here
uh but f4 saying okay uh you can grab
this pawn but then i
get my uh well if queen captures an h5 i
just push f3 and now i have a very
dangerous pass pawn
and it's very questionable if i will be
able to stop it you can stop it of
course queen h3 check followed by queen
f1 but
how are you going to eliminate it uh so
instead of allowing this
just g4 uh which also creates a pass
pawn for black
so h captures queen captures with check
rook to f5
blocking uh blocking check and now queen
back to f3 uh
not allowing this this pawn to move so
look back to f8
and now king to c2 white starts bringing
the king into the game
and rook to h8 black needs to figure out
a way
how to get this spawn uh pawns moving
but it's not
not very easy you'd have to have your
bishop for example on h6 to guard this
pawn and rook here to be able to maybe
start pushing the pawns but that's a lot
of moves so rook to h8
and queen to g for check now we have
queen to f7
king to f7 and now queen to f5 check
king to g7
and now h3 the queen guards h3 also the
h3 pawn guards
g4 and black's counter play is well
eliminated
so rook f8 preparing to push the the
past f
pawn and now queen to d7 attacking the
bishop king f7 and now
king to d3 so now uh
the rook is not behind the pawn well it
is kind of but the king is in the way so
rook the h8 going after the h3 pawn
and king to e2 now as the h3 pawn is
defended for the moment with
rook to h4 and now king to f3 keeping an
eye again on the g4 square
we have a6 by black and now simply a4
preparing b5
with king to f8 and queen to f5 with
check we have king to g7 and now queen
to e6 again going after the bishop
king f8 defending and now queen to d7
with an attack on the pawn here
so king f7 not a lot you can do about
this uh end here
uh rather than capturing and getting the
queen away from the defense of the h3
pawn
here just b5 so here we have captures
captures
and c captures on b5 but now this
this falls with check so it's okay queen
captures with check we have king to f8
and queen cactus on b7 now allowing the
capture on h3 but now the king has a
clear idea of what he's doing so
captures with check
king g4 and rook to h4 with check king
f5 and finally f3
uh black starts pushing his past pawn of
course queen captures on f3
runs into rook for check winning the
queen so
of course you're not going to do that
king to g6 and now
rook captures on d4 but now comes queen
a to
uh you have to do something bishop to d8
as the king has
no squares so bishop d8 uh and now uh
queen captures on f3 again with check
uh you could go for queen a7 followed by
some checkmating ideas but this is much
safer
so rook there for blocking and queen to
d5 now
uh we have king to e8 and now comes c6
the pawns are now
way too strong bishop to b6 and the
queen to d7 check now we have king to f8
and e6 and it was
in this position that jordan won forest
resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh so he put up
quite the resistance uh the game lasted
for 57 moves even though it was over in
move eight
but like i said resigning is not at all
fashionable
in modern chess especially in online
chess
so tari wins a very nice game just so
you know uh if you play the scandinavian
or against the scandinavian after bishop
d2 be mindful of your queen either block
it or
create an escape route for the queen
never play something like knight b
to d7 or you will lose the game terribly
as you can see even grandmasters are not
not immune to this position
so yeah once again that's the game i do
hope you enjoyed it arientari not only
won the game but he also won the match
four and half two and a half and he
advances the semi-finals where he will
face ralph mohammed of the
sea who will who will go into the finals
uh now regarding the candidates
tournament in yekaterinburg
uh uh fire stated that it will be well
also i've read that there is an
unofficial statement that
the candidates tournament will be
resumed on first of november
uh so that's like the plan a and the
player players should arrive at least
two days
before the start of the event uh but if
the situation uh
doesn't come down regarding the what's
happening in the world
uh it could be moved to some other place
so there's also a plan b
there's also a plan c so uh we still
don't know if
it will actually be held there uh or
will it uh be moved somewhere else but
yeah it will continue
uh the remaining rounds will be played
out as it is there's nothing
there are there's no talk at least so
far about uh changing anything uh there
is no
talk about uh uh or a job of being
included or anything like that
if you're interested in that uh but i
will make a separate video on that as
soon as fide issues an official
statement and i will
inform you about uh the the well
uh resuming of the free candidate at a
candidate tournament 2020.
uh but yeah that's the the game and the
news i do hope you enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank elaine goet uh
jeffrey johnson uh hannah tomas
happy birthday to sid i hope you hope
you had a very nice party and that you
will
uh you know uh keep enjoying chess and
uh
well that you will have many many great
uh so victories uh thank you all for
watching and i will see you soon guys
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world such as this very nice
game here
thank y'all i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day